everyone
thank you for attending my name is john
grimm i teach with mary evelyn tucker a
joint master's degree program at yale
forestry and environmental studies and
yale divinity school
the plan for today's panel
on the papal encyclical on the
environment is to open with a
perspective from catholic theology
and then a panel of interdisciplinary
presenters whom i will briefly introduce
followed by a question and answer
session
and a final summary by dean sterling
from yale divinity school
we are
reminded
in this room that science law ethics and
religion have been in productive
dialogue in many settings
and this afternoon is one of them
that is because here
at the center of the beautiful tiffany
stained glass windows
science and religion are portrayed in
relationship of mutual respect this
window is 125 years old
so it's interesting to think about the
dialogue of religion and science when it
was put together and here we are
carrying on that dialogue
our dialogue then is aspirational
as we develop a deepened understanding
of our different subjects of study and
research in relation to the encyclical
and it's appropriate to ask the question
what is an encyclical it is the highest
level of teaching document in the
catholic church
this is the first encyclical on the
environment and will be released this
summer
who helped pope francis the first to
write it he received advice from
scholars in the humanities then social
sciences and especially the natural
sciences
they met at the pontifical academy in
may of last year and also they drew
extensively on the intergovernmental
panel on climate change ipcc report also
theologians and ethicists on the
pontifical council on justice and peace
and others around the world have advised
the pope
how will it be brought out this document
when it comes out will probably be about
50 pages long but there will be a
summary attached to it so it will be
released on the vatican website with
translations
then through education it will reach
into universities high schools and
seminaries and then in churches from the
pulpits sermons and it will certainly
draw attention in religious education
the content of the encyclical while it
has not been released there have been
certain concepts that have been leaked
one of the major terms that will be used
is integral ecology
the
the sense of attention to people and
planet
bringing together in the concern for
environmental degradation and climate
justice
namely what's now being called
justice so this encyclical will bridge
social justice and eco-justice
the audience 1.2 billion catholics
obviously but
2 billion christians the world
conference of
churches will certainly attend to it and
we'll talk about other religious
traditions in the panel finally what are
some immediate and long-term objectives
obviously raising awareness and action
with regard to environmental concern and
this will lead this pope to
attend to
the united nations general assembly he
will address it later this year
in september and also a joint session of
congress so all of this francis is very
conscious as moving towards the december
meetings
of
the
climate discussion so let's begin
with
teresa berger professor of liturgical
studies and the thomas golden professor
of catholic theology at yale divinity
school
who will make opening comments setting
the encyclical in a catholic theological
context thank you teresa
thank you john
i have three and a half points which is
half a point more than pope francis
usually has in his sermons
i begin
with just a couple of words on the kind
of text this is for people who are not
used to reading and speaking vaticanese
this will be an encyclical that is
written in vaticanese
the text right at the moment is
the dominant version will be latin but
it will come out in other languages
these encyclicals in the last hundred
years have ranged very broadly in topic
from
issues related to
problems of the day that the popes
wanted to attend to
rights of workers the dignity of women
two
theological documents on the liturgy on
biblical interpretation and so on and so
forth
this will be the first encyclical on the
environment but it's by no means the
first word the catholic church has
spoken on the environment but that's
important
to remember
so i come with that to my second
point
pope francis is drawing not only on work
that has already been done by popes
before him who have spoken on the
environment although no not in
encyclical form he's drawing on other
movements within the catholic church
there is a global catholic climate
movement that's
its specific name is that
and a lot of smaller
groups many of the bishops conferences
for example around the world from
australia to canada to south africa have
published texts on the environment
so whatever we think about the pope
publishing an encyclical
he's not the only catholic
speaking about environmental issues he
is of course the most visible one
amongst catholics speaking on this
third and for me as a catholic
theologian this is the most important
point
it doesn't take a profit to
tell you
that this encyclical
will
embed environmental concerns in an
overarching theological
narrative
and probably what that narrative will be
is a narrative that situates the
universe within
a notion of creation that thinks about
the universe as a god sustained
as on a god sustained journey
and looks at
the universe having a telos of a point
of fulfillment
beyond
earthly realities
whatever we say again about this papal
encyclical i think we won't get to the
heart of it without an acknowledgement
of this theological
narrative another little example this
pope doesn't mince words he will
probably
talk about
the sin of exploiting the earth again a
very substantial theological category
in terms of authorities that will govern
this encyclical yes there was broad
consultation
but as vaticaneese goes this
specific speech act um i think two of
the authorities that i guarantee will be
in there are the scriptures
the hebrew bible and the new testament
and then the tradition of the catholic
church i would bet
that there is a reference to one of the
documents of vatican ii in there
so if you want to take me up on that bet
i think you will lose but you're welcome
too
those are my three points my half point
with which i conclude is that i think
the pope will conclude the encyclical
with a gesture of
hope
which i think we all need at this point
of the ecological crisis
thank you very much teresa that's so
helpful to have your overview
let me introduce the panel in the order
in which they will speak and i will not
refer to you again so please just carry
on first peter crane dean of yale school
of forestry environmental studies we'll
speak to the issues of the important
dialogue of science and religion in
relation to the encyclical
margaret farley
gilbert stark professor emeritus of
christian ethics at yale divinity school
will address the ethics of catholic
social teachings and ecology
mary evelyn tucker co-director of the
forum on religion and ecology at yale
will offer some observations on how
other religions may respond to the
encyclical tequila chanyopa
mccluskey fellow at fes will share her
experience with buddhist monks working
on environmental issues and suggest
ways that their work will be enhanced by
the encyclical
doug kaiser joseph field professor of
law at yale law school will make
comments on how environmental law and
policy might be affected by the
encyclical
after the panel then we will open two
questions from the audience
so thank you john um it's great that we
have such a wonderful attendance here
today and i particularly want to thank
dean sterling for his efforts for
working with us to bring together our
two schools to consider this this
important issue and and i hope that's
the beginning of a longer and deeper
relationship we've only got a little bit
of time so i'm just going to kind of zip
through the things that seemed important
to me as i was thinking about this
earlier this morning
so um
obviously one can interpret uh the
significance of this encyclical at
multiple levels i'm just going to
highlight
three
first i think as a as a catalyst in
building appreciation of and willingness
to deal with climate change at a global
level john's alluded to that some degree
i'll say some more about it in a moment
second its role in
continuing to build awareness of the
strong linkages between environmental
problems of all kinds not just climate
change and fundamental issues of human
well-being and justice
and third its role in changing the
debate around environmental concerns
including climate change
from a sole focus on science and
technology and economics which is where
it's generally framed to broader
considerations of this issue in moral
ethical and for some people spiritual
terms so with regard to point one the
catalytic role
the timing as you've already heard of
this encyclical is either the result of
careful planning or a very happy
accident
because it as you've heard it will
appear over the summer as you've heard
in september the pope will speak at the
u.n in new york and to a joint session
of congress in dc where incidentally
there are 167 catholics more than any
other denomination in the congress and
crucially this comes just two months
before the conference of the parties to
the un framework convention on climate
change that will take place in paris in
early december
now since i arrived here at yale in the
summer of uh 2009. the first thing that
was on my agenda was the the copenhagen
final summit
in uh december 2009 and since
since then which was which was a very
difficult uh process did not at all
live up to what we all hoped it might
people have been working very very hard
to put the pieces together to come to
paris to conclude
uh an agreement and if you look at
what's happened over the last 18 months
you'll see that the pieces have been
steadily put in place so this is not an
encyclical that comes in isolation it's
part of a process that's been unfolding
really since copenhagen before it indeed
all the way back to
1992.
so it comes as an important
moment and it'll be an important part of
the process
that will create new impetus and a
concerted push to reach a global
agreement on climate change now that's
not going to solve all of the problems
there's much to be done at regional and
local levels but it's a very very
important kind of global state
and um tony loserowitz in our school who
thinks about how the american public
regard climate change his work recently
published work
shows that uh this encyclical at least
with regard to climate change will fall
on fertile ground because
his work shows that a solid majority of
catholics 70
think that global warming is happening
and also that catholics in the us are
significantly more worried about global
warming than other christians
so now with regard to point two the
connection to issues of of social
justice the encyclical will re-emphasize
that the world's most vulnerable people
shoulder the greatest environmental
burdens and that it's the health and
daily lives of the poor that are and
will be most impacted by environmental
degradation the pontifical academy has
already been referred to
later this month april 28th there'll be
a high level meeting at the vatican of
vatican officials plus these external
advisors from science business
diplomatic corps development religious
leaders academicians and so on and the
un secretary general and to quote from
the kind of preamble to that meeting the
aim will be
to raise awareness and build consensus
that the values of sustainable
development
cohere with the values of the leading
religious traditions with a special
focus on the most vulnerable to elevate
the debate on the moral dimensions of
protecting the environment in advance of
the papal encyclical and to help build a
global movement across all religions for
sustainable development and climate
change through 2015 and beyond
so with regard to point three changing
the nature
of the debate part of the outcome of
that meeting that i mentioned and again
i'm quoting from the documents
a joint statement on the moral and
religious imperative of sustainable
development highlighting the intrinsic
connection between respect for the
environment and respect for people
especially the poor the excluded
children and future generations
so as this indicates the encyclical will
give new prominence
to the ethical moral dimensions of
environmental degradation including
climate change
and this will perhaps will be
you could think of the climate
negotiations themselves being a kind of
a short-term win but the kind of
longer-term win
will be
as these ideas become incorporated
into catholic teaching with its fast
reach but also as they seek as that
window does to bridge the divide between
science and religion
so speaking as a scientist
science and religion
in their own ways
both awaken a sense of awe and wonder of
the complexity of beautiful
uh complexity and beauty of life
and combined with the indisputable link
between the health of people and
communities and the health of the
environment the encyclical will
emphasize
the care and humility that's needed in
our relationship to the natural world
and that that has moral and ethical
dimensions
a little under a year ago the pope made
a short speech in which he emphasized
quote the beauty of nature and the
grandeur of the cosmos he emphasized
that that was a christian value
as a scientist i'd go further i'd say
it's a universal value and it's a
universal value that i think most
scientists would subscribe to
with enthusiasm
i changed the title of the
event slightly
to read a letter from pope francis on
climate and environment
why a papal encyclical may
matter
we don't know yet that it really will
something matters to us when it is
important to our loves our fears our
needs
our convictions
or even our puzzlements
ordinarily papal encyclicals offer
teachings that are meant to be taken
seriously by roman catholics
not necessarily as absolute doctrines
but as official articulations
of religious and moral understandings
they aim to clarify religious beliefs
and ethical issues
and to inspire those who read or hear
about them
they may engender disagreements
over some of their content
and they may illuminate change in church
practice and belief
moving from earlier articulations to
more adequate
insights
and imperatives
in response to the question then
as to why a new encyclical on the
environment
might matter
to roman catholics and even to a wider
audience
the answer as i see it is not that
suddenly every hearer will feel bound to
act in accordance with what is said
it is rather
that attention will be paid
to what is offered
dialogue will ensue
new insights may grow
and new experiences of moral claims
regarding climate environment and crisis
will awaken within us
let me propose some examples of what
might may be included in such an
encyclical
that may make it
matter uh significant for us
so first
the encyclical can offer what are new
perspectives for many
not all and i suspect for
for most of you these are not new
new perspectives for many on the
relationship that ought to be between
human persons and nature
from relations primarily of utility
domination exploitation
nature human relations may instead
be based
on the intrinsic value inherent in each
and in all non-living living
non-human
and human beings
each has both instrumental
and intrinsic value
created
and held in being by god
beautiful in themselves with a telos
and finality
nature and humanity are not thereby
wholly separated from one another
whether over against or in
complementarity
humanity is situated within
nature in a broader view
of nature
the relationship is one of
interdependence
participation
and for humans the possibility of
conscious love
gratitude and awe
for pope francis
this yields
in many of his
even off the cuff uh
speakings
for him this yields a religious
obligation
to protect creation
to care about the work of god
to nurture rather than diminish the
possibilities of both nature and
humanity
a second example of an important
perspective for inclusion in the
encyclical if it is to matter to many of
us
is the development of skills and
sensibilities for moral discernment
resources for moral discernment and
action
are available in particular
in the roman catholic tradition known as
catholic social teaching
from the late 19th century on
this tradition has been expanded and
refined
so that issues of justice
such as racism economic inequities
just wages
rights of workers to organize
war and peace
nuclear disarmament and so on
have been taken up by scholars as well
as church leaders
human and legal rights theories have
been developed
and applied in response to moral
imperatives undergirded by principles
such as respect for the dignity of every
individual
concern for the common good
solidarity in and among communities
religious liberty
etc
with these have come ethical claims for
justice and care
not only in one's own group but in
relation to all peoples
including future generations
these kinds of efforts have brought
together issues
in environmental ethics
linking for example
negatively
economic exclusion and inequality
with
ecological devastation
linking positively
care for all of creation and the
principle of preparation preferential
option for the poor
this kind of analysis has been cited by
pope francis on multiple occasions
also
new
understandings of natural law
have allowed the questioning of rigid
notions of eternal order
and the importance not only of
understanding human and non-human
suffering
but the work of the sciences in the
service of ecological restoration and
protection
an encyclical that can touch the
consciences of people on such issues
will surely matter to the world of the
present and the future
there are many other examples to be
tapped in probing problems and
perspectives that matter
for those who may receive such an
encyclical
problems such as population growth
in relation to the environment
and women's burdens which escalate with
the devastation of sources for water and
food
extreme poverty
and the circumscription
of options for education
the encyclical to be focused on climate
and environment
could go a long way towards simply
understanding and challenging these
kinds of needs
and longer still toward remedying them
if it fails to do so
the crises before us may only increase
perhaps either way we shall learn more
about what really matters in our lives
and the world in which we live
thank you fellow panelists
i'm going to speak just briefly at the
beginning to say
this encyclical will affect christians
around the world as tony lacera with his
polling has shown and the yale project
on climate communications has been
essential the jesuits are going to take
it into education they have schools and
universities around the world the world
council of churches is already moving
forward on this the patriarch of the
greek orthodox church has been working
for more than 15 years on these issues
as a good friend of the pope and as well
there's an evangelical environmental
network here in the u.s there's people
here in the audience like patrick and
others and andrew who are working on
this issue
but i'm going to really address the
question of what are other religions uh
going to do with this encyclical now
clearly this is going to be somewhat
speculative but
why will this
encyclical reach out beyond the
christian world
there are more than a billion muslims a
billion hindus a billion confusions
who will be hearing this call to action
and while it's difficult to predict
their response i'll offer a few general
observations focused on asia where
nearly two-thirds of the world's people
live
this is an area that i've studied and
traveled in for over 40 years especially
china japan and india the rapid changes
i have seen during those four decades is
why i am doing this work with john and
many many others in religion and ecology
so that the diverse environmental ethics
of the world's religions will be part of
the search for environmental solutions
as we know people's cultural norms and
religious values matter enormously in
changing attitudes and behavior
clearly asia is increasing in its
importance for the future of the planet
with rapid industrialization in india
and china over 2 billion people in these
countries are yearning for the fruits of
modernization
but the cost has been immense in terms
of pollution of air water soil as well
as loss of biodiversity the health of
both people and planet is being greatly
stressed
and the ecosystems especially a recent
youtube series called under the dome
showed the dangerous levels of
pollutions in chinese cities this was
viewed by over 250 million people in
china before it was shut down but the
mere fact that it was on says the
government as well as local people know
that they are up against some serious
serious problems you can watch it here
in the west though how to address these
problems then is not easy for more than
40 years since the stockholm conference
of 1972 environmental scientists and
policy makers lawyers and economists
have been struggling with these
competing issues of environmental
protection and economic development such
as we see in asia
as another approach we have worked to
include cultural and religious values as
part of the solution to environmental
problems over the last 20 years the
forum on religion and ecology with many
people around the world have been
drawing together the research of
scholars and theologians of the world's
religions to identify
theology ethics and practice regarding
ecology and justice from these
traditions in books journals and films
the pope's encyclical then will help to
awaken an even broader response
among the religious traditions and build
on the work that has been done
let me suggest several ways that this
will happen
as peter mentioned the pope is convening
in april later in april a conference of
religious leaders at the vatican
to focus on climate change the secretary
general of the u.n will be there but the
pope will urge these leaders to join him
in speaking out on the human suffering
that climate change is causing
especially for the poor
this will clearly encourage religious
leaders to address these issues in the
language of their own traditions as the
karmapa did here yesterday at yale in a
magnificent
talk on the values of buddhism for
conservation 2500 people were there
listening to this talk
his influence the karmapa's influence
along with the dalai lama extends to
millions of people throughout the
himalaya region and well beyond tequila
will be describing her work with the
karmapa to involve 50 monasteries
in environmental protection i could
speak of other religious leaders in
india as well
but the encyclical will spark even
further exploration of the resources for
environmental ethics in the traditions
of india hinduism jainism buddhism and
of china confucianism and taoism
the harvard books on these religious
traditions and ecology that many of us
have been involved in have been
published in india and translated into
into chinese conferences are now
proliferating in china that are focused
on this term ecological civilization
which the chinese are trying to bring
forth on a government level on an
academic level and on a popular level
because they know they are up against
these limits
and they're basing these on their
ethical values of their traditions
so in addition the fastest growing
religion in china is actually
christianity there are 100 million
christians in china more than 85 million
members of the communist party which are
considered atheists so these christian
groups will certainly be influenced by
the message of the encyclical especially
as they are living in regions adversely
affected by environmental problems and
climate change
the encyclical then will speak to
leaders and laity in many religious
traditions it will deepen the moral
awakening to ecology and justice as one
issue
eco-justice it will ignite a groundswell
of concern
for addressing these challenges in terms
of both science and religion
ecology and ethics as this panel
illustrates
let us hope that here at yale we will
also respond to environment and climate
change challenges not just at the school
of forestry and divinity
but with a broadened attention in our
curricular choices and sustainability
practices for preparing all of our
students to contribute to a flourishing
future thank you very much
good evening
good evening
thank you for having me here um
i thought before i started talking about
the work i've been doing with ben
buddhist monasteries i would do a small
overview of how climate change is
affecting the himalayas um as many of
you know uh the twin plateau and the
himalayas are the
the main source for seven great
freshwater rivers in in mainland asia
and this includes everything from indus
to the ganges brahmaputra
ian does how about this
um the indus
the ganges the brahmaputra salween
mekong erawadi and the yellow and the
yangtze rivers so the source of all of
these rivers actually are in the tibetan
plateau and as you can imagine as
climate change starts to affect
how water is stored in the tiban plateau
it obviously is going to affect billions
of over a billion people easily in
mainland asia
one of the biggest challenges of climate
change is that actually the impacts are
being felt much more rapidly in the
mountain areas than in the rest of the
world and certainly in the lowlands of
india and
pakistan
nepal and bhutan
so when we think about climate change
there what we're looking at is
increasing temperature
glacial retreat uh snowmelt a lot more
snowmelt which is leading to glacial
lake outbursts
and floods and then in contrast droughts
and it often happens within a
three-month gap that you're going to
have floods in the beginning of a
monsoon and all of a sudden the monsoon
tapers and you end up with a major
drought
in terms of how communities are affected
in the area of course you have immediate
disasters and that's what most people
think of when they think of
impacts
from climate change in among people
right so usually it is um
it's a lot of people that get displaced
or that are actually injured people that
die roads that are blocked off and so on
but there's also
a deeper problem that's going on which
is that of the loss of livelihoods and
and the changes in crop patterns so
we're also talking about mass hunger
that's moving in into the region but
people aren't able to identify that as a
climate change problem or an impact that
that is happening because of climate
change
and there is a third issue that comes in
that
governments seem to be becoming very
aware of but i would say society isn't
picking up on which is conflict
you know before i created this program
to work with religious leaders i worked
in the mekong region and the first time
we had a
climate change adaptation conference for
the reach the entire region in the
mekong what was really surprising was
that the governments were sending
military advisors to these conferences
and that actually the governments were
much more aware was seeing climate
change as a major cause for future
conflict we certainly see it already in
the himalayan region with a lot of
refugees moving in from bangladesh and
how that actually changes society and
how that changes how communities
access to natural resources
so these are some of the impacts that we
are seeing in the himalayas um
i think some of the biggest challenges
in terms of addressing such impacts
include the lack of awareness of course
and most of us probably deal with this
at some level or the other there is then
the opposite problem which is there is
too much awareness and so people are
completely frozen there is the state of
paralysis
people don't know who should be
responsible there is a sense that it's
somebody else more important or
you know more
civically engaged should actually be
responsible for this problem
and i think what that leads to is a
situation where the communities are
incredibly disempowered they understand
that what they are seeing is caused by
climate change and unlike in the u.s or
the uk or even australia in the
himalayas and in most places i've worked
in around the world people people will
really believe that it is climate change
that's causing these problems
so
so
um so going back to this state of
paralysis and this frustration one of
the biggest challenges we face is how do
we make the communities empowered to
become more resilient and to be able to
adapt well to to climb
and in my case because i began working
for his holiness the karmapa i hope some
of you got to hear him speak yesterday
i began working with a group of
monasteries in the himalayas and he
actually had asked me to
start training
monks and nuns on environmental issues
and start providing science training
basically so they could understand
what's going on in their communities and
what came out of it was
an eco-monastic movement that's led by
him with 55 monasteries that do
environmental projects and
there are several kinds of project
impacts that have come in the last eight
years so of course you have their own
footprints so the immediate footprint
that you know some of these monasteries
have 5 000 monks and nuns in their
community so
when they buy from the local markets
they you know they they have trucks they
have cars and so on they build buildings
and massive concrete buildings sometimes
so they have their own footprint and
being able to change that footprint
there is the moral leadership that
everybody has mentioned here that they
actually have this
enormous sway in how communities see
different issues and how
they are
in some sense
triggered to think about issues and to
feel about issues
i think
another thing that i've noticed in terms
of impacts by engaging them is that we
see a ripple effect when they get
involved in something
so an example i can give is that in
nepal all the monasteries in nepal
actually pick climate change as their
number one issue because nepal is one of
those places where first of all there's
a lot of knowledge actually on the
ground but secondly it's something
that's very visibly felt it's very
visible to them and they they feel the
impacts almost immediately
there have been a lot of glacial lake
outbursts a lot of flooding a lot of
drought in that area
and the news often carries information
including how wildlife is treated
there's a lot of information about how
tigers are moving up land you know the
tree line is shifting and so generally
speaking in nepal there's a lot more
awareness
all the monasteries chose to build solar
and use solar and there are what i've
noticed from
in terms of the project activities that
work is that it's the win-win it's the
combinations that work so in nepal
another big problem that you have if for
those of you who might know it is that
there's a lot of load shedding the power
usually you have it for maybe four or
five hours and that's the amount of
electricity you're going to get and so
for monasteries to pick solar it really
is a win-win for them they have an
independent source of energy but they
also know that they are doing what they
can to address climate change
when these monasteries decided to do
solar they put it in the most visible
places they could find often you know
right where the golden dome is on top of
a mastery on top of the temple um
and what we've seen is that actually
there's almost a circle of effects
actually does a very visible
environmental project we see that the
communities start adapting and picking
it up very quickly
another thing that they picked up was
organic gardens and again it was a
win-win it was something that was
healthy that they knew affected their
diet and made them more healthy but at
the same time it also went back to this
idea of being more resilient to climate
change disasters and again we saw we saw
a growing impact in the community and
more and more communities started doing
this so
in having monasteries become engaged has
definitely made a huge difference in
terms of how i think the conservation
community is also speaking about climate
change and how they're adapting to it um
but at the same time the the monks and
nuns themselves have expressed many
times that they feel really lost and
there is this moment where they are
incredibly empowered and they feel like
they're doing whatever it is they can
and then there is this pause when they
say but what comes next and there is no
global agreement and they do actually
track what's happening at a global level
the sort of frustration what probably
every one of us feels about lima and so
on and so they go through that too
this is where i think the papal
encyclical matters so much because going
back to what is holiness said yesterday
there was a brilliant question from the
audience about what do you do you know
when you feel frustrated and depressed
and so on and he said you have to be
part of a community because that's what
sustains you
and
i think what's what we're seeing more i
mean what we're seeing incredibly you
know that's incredible right now is that
religions actually converging on this
issue it is a moment of convergence it's
not just one religious leader that's
speaking up on it or that's been
hammering at the door you know talking
about climate change we're seeing a sort
of chorus of voices coming around the
world
and i know for the monks and nuns we
actually have talked about the pope
quite a bit and social justice because
this isn't eco justice isn't how they
see the world and so for them to start
putting these issues together and to
recognize that other religious leaders
and other religious communities are
doing what they are doing as well
i think is is actually ultimately the
most empowering thing that can happen
for them so what i see
as a
as a sign of hope more than anything
else is that
there is such a movement working around
the world and it is not just a
theoretical movement as an activist i
must say that is the most positive thing
i see it is a very practical movement
that it's not simply the pope is putting
that in cyclical and it's going to stop
there that actually churches are doing
what they can to also change their own
footprint and the monasteries across the
himalayas and you know all the other
religious institutions that are working
on this around the world are are
actually changing their own footprint
while trying to also
get the rest of us to join them and see
it as a moral obligation and right thank
you
oh no here comes the lawyer
actually throughout these remarks i've
been entranced by the image of a
beautiful little knitted boot poking out
from this infant car seat being gently
rocked by the gentleman in the front row
and i'm tempted to just scrap my remarks
and have us all listen
and watch for five minutes while a baby
sleeps
but i won't
so despite efforts to manufacture doubt
about climate science responsible policy
makers have actually accepted the
seriousness of the problem for quite a
long time
indeed in 1992 the nations of the world
negotiated the u.n framework convention
on climate change that dean crane
mentioned known as the unf triple c
and in that document nations oblige
themselves to adopt policies with the
goal of quote preventing dangerous
anthropogenic interference with earth's
climate system
now this obligation already exists as a
matter of international law but in the
years since 1992 we've seen a steady
rise in global greenhouse gas emissions
punctuated only by an occasional
regional or global economic crisis
which seems to be the only thing that's
capable of slowing the growth in
emissions so
why has the unf triple c failed to
generate meaningful climate action
it is not for lack of available policy
tools
indeed despite efforts to manufacture
doubt about the economic sensibility of
adopting climate mitigation policies
we've known for a long time that a price
on carbon is the simplest and most
effective climate mitigation policy
available to us
up a little more
we want to hear your every word okay
so just think
if the u.s congress got its act together
we could reach 80 percent of our
country's greenhouse gas emissions by
regulating fewer than 3 000 entities
through an upstream carbon tax
we could start collecting this tax
tomorrow because the necessary entities
are already subject to administrative
tax collection regimes and tomorrow we
could also start returning the economic
value of that tax to individuals through
a linked reduction in payroll taxes the
logic of this policy is so simple a
kindergartner could grasp it but our
congress cannot
tax bad things not good things pollution
is bad employment is good voila
so
why have we failed to adopt this simple
and obvious policy that would help to
fulfill the urgent climate
responsibilities that we have already
acknowledged and accepted as a matter of
international law
the answer is complex and i can only
offer here a very crude
digested version but it goes like this
because the global climate policy
process has been held hostage by a
country
this country which has found its own
political process held hostage by
economic interests that are capable of
investing not only in traditional
capital but also in the capture of laws
and institutions that are intended to
regulate capital so that more and more
the rewards from human cooperation
accrue in unequal proportions to a
self-perpetuating and unaccountable
elite
so
now i can answer the question posed to
this panel of why the forthcoming
encyclical is important the encyclical
is important because pope francis will
not merely address climate change and
humanity's obligation of planetary
stewardship
he will address those issues within the
context of what he calls an integral
ecology that encompasses concerns of
economic justice
true human development and global
solidarity
pope francis recognizes as he said
during his all saints day homily last
year
that we are capable of devastating the
earth far better than the angels
and he continued this is exactly what we
are doing we destroy creation we
devastate lives we devastate cultures we
devastate values we ravage hope
he also recognizes as he told the world
meeting of popular movements that an
economic system centered on the god of
money needs to plunder nature to sustain
the frenetic rhythm of consumption that
is inherent to it
and finally as he told delegates to the
triple c last year pope francis
recognizes that the effective struggle
against global warming will only be
possible with a responsible collective
answer that goes beyond particular
interest and behavior and is developed
free of political and economic pressures
climate change may be the most pressing
most wicked environmental problem facing
humankind but it may also be our best
opportunity to address underlying
economic political and cultural diseases
that give climate change its appearance
of inevitability
the encyclical will help to diagnose and
minister to those underlying pathologies
so that if we do indeed heal the planet
we may also have a humanity worthy of
inheriting it thank you
we now have the happy occasion to have
some exchange with the panel members
theresa may ask you to take my place
here to join us
and i'd like to ask you to come forward
to the microphones because we are
streaming this event
so please take the opportunity to move
towards the microphones and off just a
final reminder
let's frame a question rather than make
a lengthy comment
please thanks thank you john
and thank you all for uh um organizing
this discussion a lot of people are
having talks about what to do after the
encyclical comes out so it's nice
although not surprising that you all
would do something before it comes out
it's very nice my question is and i
think margaret had talked about
reframing the question i would reframe
it to how do we ensure that the
encyclical matters and how do we ensure
that it matters not to theologians with
all due respect to all of you folks up
on the panel um but to common everyday
people how do we ensure that it matters
in such a way that people are called to
action move to change and move to get
out of the pews and out to the streets
thanks
is there a ready taker or should we have
another question maybe two questions
good let's do that please
uh what are the chances do you think
that the namesake of
saint francis
uh is going to issue a universal call
for vegetarianism
and if not why not
shall we draw some sauce please do speak
up panel well we had a call for
vegetarianism last night from the
karmapa
many of us have been vegetarian for a
long long time it is one thing one can
do but i think to patrick's question uh
i think it's inevitable that this will
trickle down
if you will
but also trickle up i was at a
conference at the jesuit university
loyola in chicago just two weeks ago the
jesuits have the largest private
education system in the world there's
230 house
colleges and universities and there's
2500 high schools and they are going to
take this they already are into a
curriculum that has science and values
put together with an online textbook
they are also having jesuits and
scientists meet at the stockholm
resilience center in in sweden and take
those conferences to every continent to
rev up this sense that the science is
here the moral moment is also here i
think it's very helpful thank you
james
diquila was struck by your the ripple
effect of these monasteries working
together and i think institutionally
both the academic institutions like yale
and also faith-based institutions what
are the things that work well for
getting institutional
power motivated towards that ripple
effect or really
with leadership and with buy-in from the
from those communities
wow
that's a big question uh well you know i
created when i created this program i
was with the world wildlife fund and uh
it was a unexpected moment for me i was
just a field conservationist um that
suddenly learned that actually working
with religious leaders meant
um two things one was that uh yes you
changed and you know you decided to pick
up different environmental values and
behavior but that you also felt like you
were a better religious person and
because it happened personally i found
that i could actually convince other
people so i think what was the big
lesson learned for me creating this
program at wwf and getting buy-in in a
very science-based institution was that
actually it was the experience and the
emotions that changed other people's
minds it wasn't the science despite what
most scientists think
it wasn't the data that actually
people's minds um but i think that's
what we fall back on i think that's what
we trust and rely on and i think it has
a lot to do with our own identity and
what we value that we sort of fall back
on that to convince other people and
institutions um and this is where
religious leadership is so crucial of
course because they know exactly what it
is that makes humans tick and you know
they know way better than us scientists
or or maybe even lawyers
you know that how that works um
so i think there has to be a space for
that and for a discussion around how we
feel what actually motivates us to do
good things just generally speaking and
what is it that we're concerned about in
terms of um how climate change is
affecting us and what we need to do and
this is where the pope matters so much
thank you tequila let's take two
questions from this side
yes
blanket here uh why should we believe
that this encyclo
encyclical will have an impact when
the church's teaching on contraception
hasn't you know you can make the
argument regardless of whether
you know whether the church's teaching
is
solid or not it's been consistent
insistent
it has had no impact on behavior of
catholics at least in north america in
europe
why should we be optimistic that
there'll be an impact of this encyclical
thank you
can i respond
to that
okay
only because i actually started jotting
down some ideas responding to the
question of impact that i think will be
relevant here
the the first one is
simply that i think we will be
benefiting from the francis effect
if this encyclical had been published by
benedict the 16th
i guarantee that it would not have
received half as much attention as this
encyclical will
the second point why its impact i think
will be
significantly larger than that of
previous recent encyclicals has to do
with social media their power is
increasing
and i think the pope will harness that
the vatican actually has a quite media
savvy
presence in cyber space
uh there was a third reason and i'm
blanking on it so we'll come back to
professor farley well just quickly too
there are lots of reasons but
um
i have uh
long thought that in the psyche of roman
catholics there is the need for things
to make sense
and the encyclical on contraception has
not made sense
because you're clapping so vigorously
why don't you take the next question
i can't imagine a catholic woman would
collapse so vigorously on that
hi my name is nicole perrone i'm at the
divinity school this was great i was
wondering for a lot of us in the room we
are involved on a more grassroots level
with some of the things that are are
happening in especially in the roman
catholic church and i'm wondering what
suggestions the panel might make for us
to take and roll with this encyclical i
know the u.s bishops will be rolling out
a lot of resources this summer but what
can a parish do or
theoretically a campus ministry do to
actually have an impact
that's a great question let's think for
a moment and let's have another question
also please
uh thank you for your comments um my
question is a growing number of
scientists are now saying that the un's
global warming target of 2 degrees
celsius is too high to prevent
catastrophic impacts and last december a
group of catholic bishops
internationally demanded a limit of 1.5
degrees
which would require an even more
dramatic break from
from economic orthodoxy
my question is is there any prospect of
the pope himself endorsing such a more
ambitious target
i wanted to just speak to the first one
it's very doubtful that the pope will
make a prediction on what percentage i
think right peter
but i think um already there are many
catholic and broader christian groups
working on this issue as you well know
and many of them are identified on the
forum on religion ecology website i
would just refer you to interfaith power
and light which is in 40 states already
working on carbon footprint with not
only christian groups but jewish groups
islamic groups and others across the
country about to meet in may uh they are
very catalyst that others have referred
to thank you
on the issue of um you know are the
targets right i think mary eva is right
i mean
i'm sure the pope will not go into
the kind of details of the un f triple c
um but i think more broadly uh we should
we should be very careful about being
overly pessimistic um you know we should
be very careful that the perfect is not
the enemy the good here uh you know
we've been working on this since 1992 we
haven't managed to get it done if we get
something done in paris that's a cause
for celebration but i think what the
the encyclical is part of a
of a kind of an alternate route
in a sense it's a kind of an end run
around the paralysis that doug
described
and
we don't know whether that end run will
work
but it certainly will create a new
dynamic
uh i think in combination with
uh what's being said by other religious
leaders
we're approaching uh dean sterling's i'm
intrigued by peter's comment about how
many catholics there are in the congress
and if you take that and compare it to
the
final comments about how we've had
very you know no chance at all for an
effective climate policy and how you
know margaret valley's talk about the
social justice aspect of and how usually
important this is um i'm wondering if
there's um
how can we imagine the right kind of
conversation
in the congress and with the catholic
community in the united states about the
fact that this is not only about us
right and that it's also about uh social
justice which is so central to
catholicism
thank you please
hiya uh thanks everyone for your
comments it's been great um my question
kind of goes to what you were saying
tequila around messaging and almost uh
an overburdening of negative information
and just kind of nihilism and defeatism
around this
and thinking particularly then around
young people and a lack of religious
belief how do we pivot these sort of
conversations
to combat
some of the nihilism that does exist
around climate change
and how do we pivot towards hope and
opportunity rather than
large-scale pessimism and defeatism
thank you thank you good question
related questions please would you
a twist on the contraception question if
i may
we know that overpopulation is one of
the greatest causes of environmental
degradation
and we know that in the poorest parts of
our country our world like sub-saharan
africa women are having an average of
seven children um now there is
population decline in wealthier european
countries it's true
but we know the pope has been very clear
he's not going to change the doctrine on
contraception
why should we take what he has to say
seriously on overpopulation then and how
do you think he might work around
good thank you thank you
may i thanks though
i'd like to make an observation about
this conversation
that speaks to the question of pessimism
and nihilism versus hope um
from from the climate science
perspective we now have a concentration
level of carbon dioxide
that the earth has not seen in 800 000
years
and our models tell us that even if we
stopped emitting all greenhouse gases
tomorrow it would be well over
a thousand years before we get back to
the level of concentrations we had
before industrialization so from a
lawyer's perspective this is a
problem that has a time horizon that's
simply unfathomable i mean in the us two
years is our time of policy horizon
because that's the re-election cycle in
the house of representatives so when
when dean crane said
that one could imagine action both the
scientists in the room and those from a
religious position in the room are
imagining a much much much longer
horizon of meaning
than us lawyers ever could conceive them
and i think that's a wonderful
synchronicity between the two dialogues
professor farley
well i could just say i've been reading
a fair amount of what uh
pope francis has been saying in
especially in the philippines but in
other places as well
about uh
uh
controlling
birth
and uh even though he has certainly not
gone to the point of saying
all forms of contraception are good
he certainly has been very clear
that there is no obligation to keep
having children
and
after a a point where one cannot
responsibly care for them etc
and that uh it's a it's it may be even
moral failure
if they're not encouraged
to
uh
well the the catholic term responsible
family planning
so i i actually have become a little
hopeful about that
that he's reasonable
on what the consequences are good or bad
and uh and i think that
with with his own you know when you work
on something yourself you get to kind of
believe in it too so if he
if he uh
the whole process
of producing this encyclical
may in fact also
change his minds on on some things just
as we change our minds on some things
when we work through things further and
further so
i'm not totally i'm not
totally pessim i'm less pessimistic than
i ever had
i'm less pessimistic than i have been
for many many years
two brief remarks by panelists please
mary evelyn and tequila
um i think this hope and pessimism
question is quite huge and i'm glad to
hear margaret's uh hope
you know
i just wanted to put into the mix that
our quaker friends are here
civil rights and abolition were changed
by the religious communities the quakers
in england and the religious communities
here in the u.s i'm a 60s person it was
a transformative moment this is the
moment for
environmental issues to come together
with those justice issues but i would
also say we haven't held up another huge
change agent and that is certainly what
bill mckibben has done with 350.org
against all odds has created a worldwide
movement and bill has been a great ally
in this work with religions and ecology
absolutely
a partner for 15 years on this and i
would suggest that the movement that
he's promoting at the moment on
divestment is absolutely central the
world council of churches has gone to
divestment the ucc churches have gone to
divestment the anglican church is
thinking about it the episcopal church
in this country has two billion dollars
in pension funds they're considering
this these are agents of change so
there's a range of them and i would just
say that the philanthropy community
including the rockefeller brothers who
divested and that was an amazing moment
after the climate change march where
incidentally among 400 000 people there
were 10 000 people from the religious
communities but my understanding is that
people within the philanthropy
communities are very keenly interested
in figuring out ways to engage uh their
religious communities and i think this
is very very helpful as well thank you
tequila
so um going back to this uh the trying
to pivot towards hope um actually
there's so much to be learned from the
catholic church about this um i was part
of this um event the world youth day i
don't know how many of you know about it
but it's the largest pilgrimage event
that happens in the world and it's
basically a week when the pope directly
connects with you catholic youth most of
them are you know teenagers between the
ages of 13 and
20 let's say 20 25 it sort of stretches
i noticed but usually it's people who
are who are teenagers that come and
um
going back to this sense of euphoria
this this
the uplifting that you experience when
you are first actually coming to terms
with your spiritual identity you
basically watch this unfold and you're
watching parents who are shoving their
kids out there to go be part of this
spiritual experience right and to me
what i learned watching that was that
you know i had to go back to my hippie
roots watching all of this happen
because there's a lot of mud and
hysteria and a lot of endorphins and all
of that going on but it was this moment
of realizing that actually this is why
movements matter this is why being part
of a community matters so much because
we actually are taking on a collective
identity that is way greater than our
own personal one and that when that is
the collective identity is a positive
one and is a one geared towards moving
and creating change in our societies it
naturally is an uplifting experience so
i think if we are actually
helping make that happen or leading
towards that kind of change
we are naturally working towards hope
with the panel's permission i'd like to
invite dean greg sterling of yale
divinity school to make summary remarks
knowing that i stand between you and a
glass of wine i make the same promise
henry viii made to his wives i won't
keep you long
i
i find it absolutely heartwarming to see
this audience
filled uh
at the prospect this is an audience of
faith obviously because this document is
not yet a reality
but that we are all here uh
to think about the significance of this
statement and i'm going to just try to
summarize what i consider the highlights
of what's been said
to to make us remember i hope uh
why it will be important to read this
document
let me begin with demographics
16
of the world's population are
catholics that is larger
than the number of hindus
it is larger than the number of
buddhists and it is larger
than any other single religion other
than
the muslim
muslims or the isl the faith of islam
uh
catholics are half
of the christians in our world
so
whatever one thinks
they're going to be a lot of people in
this world who read this document
because it will come from
the head 25 24 of the u.s population's
roman catholic
secondly
peter made the point that the timing of
this
is absolutely crucial because it is set
to build towards and to give
impetus towards
the discussions that will take place in
paris
next december this coming december
and i think that
this should
help
give some momentum
in that direction
something that has not been said which i
think
should be said
is in my mind there are two people in
our world who have real
moral authority universally
one is the dalai lama
and the others the pope
i mean people who when they speak
regardless of whether you're a person of
faith or completely secular we actually
take notice of what these people said
whether it's a dalai lama telling the
chinese government that he will not be
reincarnated
or whether it's the pope
making a statement on the environment we
listen
because they have a moral standing
that is unique
i hope this is a hope that the comments
that mary evelyn and that dekita have
made
will become a reality that the document
and all of the discussions will serve
both as catalyst
for others to make their voices more
prominent
and to build a chorus
of voices of people who are already
expressing those but will give them
an international platform that they may
lack in a local context
and the last thing that i want to say
is
if i were to put it crudely it's the
right thing to do
and what i mean by that more in a more
sophisticated way is what
margaret and teresa
have said
about
theological narratives or about
nurturing rather than diminishing
the relationship between nature and
humanity
it is the realization that as human
beings we are part of this world and
it's a way
of moving this discussion
not that it's not taken place but of
giving a prominence to the discussion in
a religious
framework that it has not had before
there will be people who are christians
who will oppose what is said in this
document i'm sure
but they will no longer be able to
respond simply on pseudo-scientific
grounds they will now have to respond on
religious
slash moral slash theological grounds
and i think that's healthy
so
the the takeaway that i have from this
is looking at the amount of interest
here
coming back to john's opening point
this is a
an opportunity for those
coming at this from a scientific
perspective
those of us who think of it from a
theological
framework
to join forces
to make sure
that what happened in 1992 and is
basically sat on the table
doesn't happen again in 2015 but that
there is real action and real movement
in what takes place and this audience
gives me hope that that will actually
take place thank you very much
i'm
please join us for a reception in this
space right off to my left your right
thank you again for coming
you